The AIDS pandemic can seem massive and overwhelming,...
...but the fact is, that it is solvable. It is containable. It is stoppable.
We are already engaged in that process.
Through the work of Dignitas and through the work of many many other organizations that we touch through our policy work,...
...we are having an impact for the first time in the course of the epidemic.
We're actually seeing a very significant drop...
...in the incidents of new cases of HIV in the developing world.
And people participate in the Give a Day campaign, when they actually give a day's pay to this campaign.
The outcomes are very, very significant.
It means concretely that there are people who will live because of what you've done.
It means concretely that there is new, good research that is taking place because of what you have done.
It means concretely that we are able to participate and to drive...
...policy change processes that will affect greater and greater numbers of people.
So, the give a day's pay through a Give a Day's campaign,...
...it's a very, very powerful and concrete way of having an immediate impact beyond your own individual action.